dad I'm letting you in on a huge secret
right now hey guys
okay this Friday night something really
big from descendants is going down and
just trust me you're not gonna want to
miss it
did you there's a picture-perfect town
called Seabrook where one small accident
led to a cosmic event a mysterious Brune
haze changed the fate of the world
touched by it you turned into a zombie
but we've come a long way since the
outbreak thanks to the Z bear this puppy
delivers a dose of soothing
electromagnetic pulses that keep us from
eating brains
I'm Zed and yeah I'm a zombie
today's the first day we can attend at
human high school no more classes in a
dingy basement you were saying this is
supposed to be chemistry 45 minutes ago
I was a janitor kids so bear with me
change is upon us now that zombies have
entered our school some people still
think we'll eat them
you're either approach here leader or
pro zombie could end up at the reject
table like what is this more zombie
apparel your cats living large and in
charge we're gonna let our freak flag
fly
zombies a new Disney Channel original
movie premieres Friday February 16th on
Disney Channel as they say an old zombie
tongue bizarre nutty gar same gar stick
you just thanked me for rubbing peanut
butter on your umbrella